the Nordstrom to pipeline is owned by
Russian energy concerned Gazprom the gas
it carries is also Gazprom's but a new
EU regulation says that pipeline owner
and gas provider must be different
companies as of 2020 but that would
apply to Nord Stream 2 which is still
being built so the German government is
claiming that since the pipeline is as
good as done it shouldn't come under the
looming legislation the plan is for the
1,200 kilometer long pipeline to
transport an additional 55 billion cubic
meters of Russian gas directly to
Germany the gas is needed to secure
electricity supplies now the country is
phasing out nuclear and coal power GU
countries as well as the US maintain
that a second gas pipeline across the
Baltic increases Europe's dependence on
Russia in the u.s. there have been
warnings of sanctions on European
companies taking part but Michele harms
who's just returned from Washington
thinks that's unlikely not streams fire
Nordstrom too is a difficult subject for
the Americans I made our position very
clear and I believe that the arguments
have been heard but we need to
coordinate efforts with our allies and
we shouldn't punish those companies
involved in the project often Auguste
horsemen rushing the pipeline is almost
ready if everything runs according to
plan Nord Stream 2 will enter service in
the second half of next year almond
Goncharenko joins us from our Russian
desk and bon
well what would sanctions achieve for
Washington well Washington probably
wants to stop that project and I guess
there are several reasons for that
mainly the main reason is that this
project will make Germany and Europe in
general more dependent on Russian gas
Russia is already number one supply of
gas to Germany with over 30 percent and
we all know that Jim that Russia has
used gas supplies as a political tool
against Ukraine in 2006 and 2009 by
cutting off supplies so o is such a
possibility it is from the United States
point of view and from the
vo some critics of the project in Europe
tis dangerous to make yourself
dependable I also think the United
States might probably try to postpone
the project to give Ukraine some time to
reach a new transit agreement with
Russia
so that up starting in 2020 the gas will
still be flowing through Ukraine
otherwise Ukraine will be more dependent
for Russian Prussia and more vulnerable
why then is Germany trying to skirt the
EU on laws that are meant to prevent the
abuse of supplies well I guess the
German government is trying to do what
the German economy thinks is good for
for her the German companies are
participating in that project and it is
a very lucrative project for the German
for the German business Germany will be
the major gas hub for Russian gas in
Europe and this is of course very
attractive and I also think the German
government is considering that in the
coming years Germany will Germany will
need more gas because it will it will be
giving up on atomic energy and it will
need something to substitute that it
will also also be giving up on oil or on
coal as a source of energy fossil fuels
and that is why German government is a
calculating that it will need more gas
this is why I think is the major reason
for pushing that project forward whom I
just tell me could the project still
fail I think this is very unlikely we
have only a few weeks and and and the
project will be but nearly over so it's
it's done 90% and I don't think that
anything any sanctions from the earth
can stop it come on check ankle for us
from our Russian desk in Bonn thank you
very much